a more serious crime than murder we
could probably say safely he may have
not had anything to do with her murder
yeah
very badly
[Music]
and today's special episode oh you put
some [ __ ] in her hair looks nice let's
put some shitty here that's a great way
to compliment a guy whoa do you guys
remember this theme song what's this
song oh
oh yeah that sounds good any of you guys
listen to cereal oh I can't play too
much cut it before we get blocked I
listened to the whole thing on a road
trip and it was [ __ ] sick it's dope
isn't it there's part two too right the
lady that does it Sarah Koenig or
whatever and she's legit her voice is
very good for that for that so today we
are talking about the main main story
that cereal blew up with it's called uh
well it's called cereal but the guy is a
non-side there's very very recent news
that has just come out after this very
very huge and iconic story he did it he
didn't do it no all it is is that he has
been released from prison can you give
the summary on what's going on so it's a
summary there's a a Korean chick that
disappeared and got murdered he's the
number one sister in high school they
were boyfriend girlfriend and then but
we don't know what the actual evidence
is and he's been locked up the whole
time I'll give everybody about two and a
half minutes of real real explanation
real quick okay this chick's name is
Heyman Lee she was last seen at about 3
P.M on January 13th 1999 her family
reported the 18 year old high school
student missing after she failed to pick
up her niece Lee's body was found
partially buried four weeks later in
Lincoln Park West Baltimore she had been
strangled police arrested Syed Lee's
ex-boyfriend on March 1st the pair both
attended Woodlawn High School and had
dated previous year okay according to
court records Lee had ended the
relationship in December that year Syed
was 17 when he was arrested but was
charged as an adult with first degree
murder prosecutor said Syed had killed
Lee after becoming upset when she
started dating someone else so I had
pled not guilty and his first trial
ended in a mistrial but in February 2000
he was convicted of first degree murder
and kidnapping and sentenced to life
plus 30 years in prison wow he has
always maintained his innocence and 14
years later the podcast serial brought
renewed focus on Lee's murder the case
against Syed was largely based on the
story of one witness adnan's friend Jay
who testified that he helped that
non-berry Hayes body what the oh but
Anand had always maintained he had
nothing to do with his death some people
believe he's telling the truth many
others don't across 12 episodes of
cereal the presenter and journalist
behind the podcast Sarah Koenig a former
reporter for the Baltimore Sun who also
worked on the podcast This American Life
trawled through thousands of documents
and talked to everyone she could find
who knew Syed and Lee at the same time
at the time of Lee's dead Koenig found
that there was scant forensic evidence
linking Syed to Lee's murder and that
Witnesses had changed their statements
to the police whoa questions were also
raised about the competence of saya's
lawyer and the veracity of the evidence
provided by Jay Wiles the prosecution's
key witness according to Wild's
testimony Syed told him he had killed
Lee and asked Wiles to help bury the
body but wild story changed across his
interviews with police and his timeline
did not match call logs and cell phone
tower pings so wild as they're saying is
the killer a part of a witness to the
prosecution he's the one that's saying I
helped bury the body he was the weed
dealer yeah that was like their
connection [ __ ] in jail no I
don't think so the [ __ ] I think he I
think uh because he gave up evidence and
stuff like that he was able to so he was
never in jail no no I believe wild oh
that's interesting soccer the podcast
did not come to a firm conclusion as
society's innocence or guilt but Koenig
felt there was not enough evidence to
have him convicted yeah for life too
exactly so there wasn't so much of a
firm conclusion for the podcast however
uh what is it 23 years later where are
we at right now what's the motive maybe
years later 23 years later he's now 41
years old
uh and Baltimore judge Melissa uh Finn
ruled on this past Monday September 19th
to release the now 41 year old after
prosecutors filed a motion to have his
sentence vacated wow so basically what
had happened this is a lot of
information but just want to get it out
he spent 23 years in jail on non-like
conclusive evidence which is nuts what
so the the crazy part of what brings him
out today is not that they're sure
whether or not he did or did not commit
it but rather it's because uh
in making the decision to release side
from prison uh they relied on the
extensive review of the case by
prosecutors in Maryland showing among
other things that authorities knew of at
least two alternative suspects besides
Syed in the 99 murder of haymen lay the
ex-girlfriend of his but the prosecutors
kept information about alternative
suspects from defense attorneys wow
because they're like we want an open
shut case so it's on a little bit of a
mild mistrial basically basically yeah I
wonder who the other suspects were so
now they now have 30 days to decide
whether to proceed with a new trial or
drop the charges against Syed who has
long maintained his innocence wow that's
[ __ ] that's interesting that while they
figure that out they're letting him free
yeah because it's he hasn't technically
truly been convicted of the crime
because the evidence is still not strong
enough do you guys think he did it well
now I don't
as guys that you guys have already known
this story pretty well does the general
population think that he really did it I
think it's a big split because the
podcast does a good job of like being
neutral side yeah playing both sides of
the story because one of the main things
that everybody was like this is kind of
weird was obviously he was the
ex-boyfriend right he's always the
suspect and then they would ask him like
what'd you do today and he goes I don't
remember like the day that she was gone
he kept saying like I don't know what I
did he doesn't have like a [ __ ] uh a
payment stub if anything you like
nothing what would be the motive because
he was she was dating somebody else but
I think after you listen to it I
remember feeling like I don't think he
did it or it was more of like I don't
think there's enough evidence to say
that he committed this crime with with
without a doubt but then when you hear
that there was two other suspects that
they didn't really vet out because they
really want to get this kid for whatever
reason because that's the easy one to do
yeah then it's the eyebrow raise and
then you're like dude they they could
have potentially [ __ ] up this dude's
whole life just because they weren't
doing their due diligence right and you
hear it probably all the time so it's
kind of interesting but what'd you think
after you what about what about the guy
that told him I helped them bury her
well maybe he lied or something that
that's what they kind of play him as
like they kind of hype them up as like
uh some dude that was not really
trustworthy kind of all over the place
because they they get like character
testimony from other friends and yeah
people that knew them and they were all
like yeah he was kind of a weird dude
like I don't really know what his deal
was he was kind of quiet he was like
really mysterious so no one really knew
what his true motives were isn't it
messed up that like sometimes you could
do you could definitely do something and
then if you just have not have enough
evidence you go free but sometimes you
did do something and then if they can't
convict you that sucks both ways yeah
there's uh that one HBO show that's kind
of similar to this the night a night of
yeah where it kind of like it's kind of
crazy seeing the a visual aspect of it
where you're like
sometimes you just do have a crazy night
and I think the main part of the podcast
I think in the beginning they were
really like trying to uh pressure the
dude like what do you mean you don't
know what happened it just sounds guilty
but then if you actually like go through
someone's life like sometimes there are
days you're just completely blurry like
dude what did I do that day you know I
don't even know sometimes what happened
yesterday yeah
the only way I know what I did is if I
look at my credit statement and go oh I
bought [ __ ] Ono Hawaiian Barbecue and
that's all I know that was some real
good copies
and then I removed the Taste and to
confirm uh Wilds pleaded guilty to
accessory after the fact to first degree
murder but got no prison time after
testifying against Syed see so that's
that's you gotta raise an eye yeah I
understand that so you're saying you
helped kill somebody and like bury a
body but then nothing happens because
you're you're testifying against this
guy and that's supposed to be a non's
buddy he was the weed dealer I believe
the [ __ ] he's [ __ ] so he's got more
ties to criminal activity than they need
to [ __ ] kill that [ __ ] for
ratting
a more serious crime than murder that
[ __ ] man [ __ ] a ratan what makes
this case also so uh obviously it's
complicated it's very torn between what
people believe but I think the fact that
people even have a belief Factor is a
first of its kind cereal was the first
of its kind for like the True Crime it's
so good dude right it got like 68
million plus downloads it was the first
time that like a podcast would blow to
that type of proportion and it was about
like something that was considered uh
not an ongoing case but like it was a
real life thing it's not like some dead
person's story it was like this guy's
sitting in jail and still continuing
built this entire like public this new
genre category of both entertainment and
weirdness because you're almost
capitalizing off of like victims in or
potential victims that are incarcerated
but you know it was just a huge thing
that the world just really got behind it
but brought Mass attention so many eyes
so many people are now scrutinizing the
judicial system it was kind of a first
of its kind of it was like a case study
I heard that like families of the people
in these podcasts really don't like it
because it makes them have to relive
yeah oh the Lee family has expressed
somebody said that this is uh and then
people are all weighing in on the murder
of their loved one that's pretty [ __ ]
hard you know what on a positive though
can we just celebrate the racial
interracial relationship yeah you're
right that's pretty cool yeah back in
1999 yeah that's that that's really hard
back then yeah he was Muslim and she was
Korean right yeah if you take the
potential murder part out I think
there's huge celebrations there yeah
yeah but we could we could probably say
safely he may have not had anything to
do with her murder yeah this is gonna
age very badly do we feel comfortable in
saying that we could say may feel
comfortable I don't know as soon as I
said it I was like oh I'm ready to stand
this guy all right about it that is also
a thing though to like maintain your
innocence when you've already been
cartoon for 23 years and you have life
plus 30. it's not like you have the
chance of parole in your head yeah you
know what I mean you don't know you know
within that first 14 years before the
serial podcast came out you don't know
that there's an end to this you're just
convicted yet you maintain innocence
through that entirety it sucks that we
do know that detectives for the most
part do go with the most efficient
conviction they can get yeah they're
just trying to add another score to
their [ __ ] but then also it also
sucks that an ex-boyfriend killing an
ex-girlfriend because she's dating
someone else is super common too most
murders that's kind of all those things
happen because of close people Crime of
Passion yeah did anyone ask if uh since
she's a Korean chick she might have
deserved what happened if anyone ask
that just wondering
just because you know Korean chicks are
kind of drama you know what I mean I
don't know Jesus your honor I want you
to check out exhibit a she's Korean if
you ever Korean chick
edit you know what I'm saying um
that's how the jury got deadlocked
jury's like oh my God I remember this
Korean girl I dated in college whoa I
had like two Korean girlfriends so I
understand what what you're a great case
was it difficult what happened I know I
know I know what anan's going through
[Laughter]
why was it difficult why was it
difficult yeah talk about it oh they're
just it's just they're passionate people
they're just so cinematic you know
cinematic
and this ratio of [ __ ] whites
everything's a one shot 24 frames per
second they're passionate people
yeah
talk some [ __ ] back to this dude what do
you think what do you think your honor I
think he's completely wrong I think
humans are human you have a different
experience
I think humans are here safe road
um I just tried to take the same Pro
Bart I apologize
I know I should have just ended it but
Anthony you had a Korean ex-girlfriend
didn't you yeah that's the end of the
video oh look it's 12 minutes